When I lie down and my head is on the pillow,
I feel light headed and feel like I'm moving.
Can this be iron or red blood cell deficiency?
It certainly can be a Nebia.
So getting a CBC would be in order just to test from that.
That would be, that would be number one.
Number two would be blood sugar issues.
So if you just have a blue cometer at home,
make sure you're testing your blood glucose levels
to make sure you don't have hypoglycemia.
Those would be the two biggies that I would look for.
So get that going and let's see what's going on.
The other thing you can't happen is you got to,
you know, if it's truly dizzy and you feel like you're spitting,
you could have issues with your inner canals and your beer.
That could be an issue too, but it doesn't sound like you're spitting.